Now, let's assume that we had the clause vertices connected to these variable gadgets here.
Of course, in the same way that I showed you before, so that the clause vertex
can be visited like this--paying one extra edge instead of going here if the clause can be satisfied
and we're traveling along this gadget in the right way, then otherwise
it will cost us more than one edge.
Now my question for you would be--so if the Boolean formula has a satisfying assignment,
what is the length of the shortest path from A to B, and by shortest path,
I again mean one that visits all vertices.
I want to give you the answer as before something times n plus some number times n
plus some number times mn plus some constant.